hey guys how's everyone doing hi morgan
what's up canada good morning hello
hello uh so bling and bye was so much
fun uh season one i'm so happy you guys
are back for season two kane let's start
with you first um what are you excited
for fans to see when it comes to this
new season
i think there's a lot more bling i think
the first episode one of our friends
through like a million dollar party
which is insane i think she spent like
100 flowers and that's number one number
two i think there's a lot more drama as
when i try to avoid drama i'm someone
that you know as you can tell i practice
buddhism i'm trying to like be
be compassionate to everyone but it's
difficult because you know you can't be
friends with everyone and there are new
people on the cast as well and um you
know kevin and i go through i mean we're
friends and you know we go through a bit
of little you know kind of
uh i would say a little what's better
what the drama i think um
a little hardship about friendship and
it
it
so i think that's the most important
thing you know in the end it resolves
and that's the beauty about i think
season one you know and the end there's
a resolution for
everything but in this season there
might not be some resolution for some
people i just walk off and i walk away
i'm like bye girl we're not meant to be
friends it's cool and i think uh you
know i explore a lot about my
insecurities as well and i want the
world to see that because i'm not
perfect and if you look at my instagram
and look you know you can see it looks
it might look perfect to you but i
struggle a lot with my insecurities and
i just want to share that with the world
yeah um kevin how would you say you are
in terms of opening up even more when it
comes to season two because i know you
you talk about your sobriety and you
open up even more than we've seen
yeah i think i think that's um
it's funny a lot of people aren't
comfortable opening up but to me that's
freedom you know
uh there's a saying in sobriety you're
only as sick as your secrets and so for
me i i find it more freeing to be able
to open up that way because there's
nothing to hide you know and i think
that's where a lot of insecurity for me
used to come from in the past i was i
was hiding from myself my own
insecurities my own flaws
and so i think
what i really wanted
in sharing my sobriety was to
destigmatize sobriety as well make it a
very normal thing mental health as well
and i i know a lot of people here are
big advocates of mental health and this
is just another avenue and a problem
yeah
i love that uh kim obviously we could
see the chemistry between you and kevin
in season one
it's teased in the in the trailer people
are curious so what can you tell us
about how this relationship evolves
oh my god it was very
intense you know like
i saw another side of kevin that i had
no idea he had
um
all i gotta say is this season is
shocking a lot of juicy tea like juicy
secrets that i was like what
i mean if i'm shocked i can imagine the
audience you know
um you know it's kind of like when you
watch a movie and you can predict what
happens with this
holy crap like
this is getting good
so you know um i'm really excited to
watch to be honest i haven't seen it yet
so yeah that's exciting kelly do you
feel the same way with a lot of
surprises more drama than you expected
oh definitely there were so many spiders
every turn i'm like what you know and
then you're always kind of going in you
know to a party or an event thinking you
know what's gonna happen but it just you
just you never know with a screw it can
take turns it's yeah it's a lot of
surprises definitely
i love it okay so this might be a
controversial question but everyone
talks about
everyone's outfits the fashion is like
off the charts on this show kane who do
you think is the best dress of everybody
in the cast
oh
honestly i mean i'm not the closest to
her closest to her i would say christine
has really great outfits and i always
i'm very honest with mike i might not be
the closest to her but her outfits are
bomb
amazing kevin's great
personality
[Music]
because he actually said something nice
about it oh yeah
i thought i thought he was gonna say
jamie but i said christine took me by
surprise yeah no i actually do have like
her outfits i just her fashion taste
taste and passion
it made me laugh because i think it
really i saw how hard it was for kane to
say that
so hard but at least i'm honest kevin
like i told her this in front of her
face so it's not like i'm lying i said
like you throw really great parties and
i love your outfits right i love her
fashion the taste in fashion because we
i think we do have the same pace and
fashion too so i have to give that to
her
that's cool uh can i want to ask you we
saw that your photos up on the oppenheim
group website are you an agent yes i'm a
developer and also an agent and you know
jason and i spoke um in the show came
out and i was with another brokerage
firm he's like what do you think of
doing something together i was like
let's do it you know and i did i
recently just listed a house with
krishel as well um she's one of my
co-listers and she's like hey why do you
want to give me up your listing i'm like
well just share it's fun you know we you
know although i make less money it's fun
doing it together and i always believe
in teamwork and it's been a great um
journey working with them and um you
know i and people are surprised i'm like
why are you surprised i actually work
it's not all from my parents
well you know you got something sunset
any thoughts on the christelle christine
drama i'm assuming you're team crechelle
um actually i'm i can't say on that i
actually took krishna herself but i'm
not personally mad christine she's not
done anything bad to me yeah so i have
nothing against her she's only been
supportive towards me and she's
sentenced like voice messages saying how
much she loves the show and you know so
i have nothing against her and in fact i
think she brings a lot to the table in
terms of you know adding a whole dynamic
to some sunset so i have to give her
credit for that
that's amazing um and kim i want to say
also congratulations on your residency
in vegas if you could collaborate with
any artist who would you pick
i would say
uh diplo i think he's really fun he's
actually a great friend of mine but yeah
we never really like collaborated like
on a track or anything so i think yeah
it'll be fun that's awesome kevin i
realize i didn't ask you how you would
describe the way your relation with kim
evolves this season
oh uh
can you know kim
what does right mean
exactly what is that supposed to mean
you know
uh like you know
like you know in a tornado there's
always i don't really know
it's
a hurricane it's rainy it's tumultuous
but yeah
you got to have them i guess in the
world i don't know
[Music]
whatever that means right
yep whatever that'd be for your own
interpretation
okay i love that so much you guys
congratulations on this season um
so much fun i have producers at et
canada who are like oh my god you're so
lucky you get to interview the cast so
uh congratulations thank you for your
support
check out the christine part